do you want to know how to legally pay
zero taxes and live the most beautiful
peaceful life away from political
correctness and woke ideologies we'll
then stick around until the end of this
video because I have the expert who's
going to tell us exactly how to do this
Raphael Cintron also known as a wealthy
expat on YouTube Welcome to the show how
are you thank you very much for having
me good to be in Miami and good to help
people move out of their home country
get more freedom in other places yeah
I'm really excited to have you here this
is a really hot topic I know you focus a
lot on Dubai you know leaving the Matrix
is very popular right now so I think
this is going to be really interesting
so before we delve into how to leave the
Matrix and legally pay zero taxes
legally
um can you briefly explain what you're
an expert in what is it exactly that you
offer well it all started because my
dad's an accountant and he helped a lot
of wealthy people lower their taxes
legally and then I started helping
myself basically lower my taxes as an
American Americans pay tax no matter
where you go you pay 40 you pay hundreds
of thousands of dollars in taxes I lower
my taxes legally as much as I could and
then a lot of people start asking me how
did you move to Dubai are tax Havens
real can you actually do this and I did
it through the best platform possible
which is YouTube and YouTube we educate
people we don't try to sell them
something or sell them a solution
because to a lot of people they can't do
it right now so you can't just go
tomorrow to Dubai and pay zero tax it
requires a lot of planning but I truly
believe that if you have money and if
you're making a lot of money and you
want to keep growing that money it's
your responsibility to go somewhere
where you pay zero tax or at least less
task as possible yeah and I think now is
the time because the world is getting
even crazier and there are only a few
places left which I think are immune
from all the craziness which we'll get
into
um but before we delve into that what
would you say in your expert opinion are
the best places now the best tax Havens
for 2023 and that looked good for the
next five to ten years I wouldn't say
you need to look for a tax Haven because
tax Havens typically are for example
like Bahamas which is in the news
recently for bad reasons or some islands
in the Caribbean some islands in the
Pacific if you look up tax Havens it
doesn't look good the overall image what
you should look at is countries that
have what I call a headline line tags
which are for example Dubai and the UE
we're going to have a nine percent
corporate tax and people are going crazy
about it but that's just some companies
are going to pay it most companies
specifically companies that live there
but sell outside of Dubai you pay zero
tax and if you live there as a person
let's say you're a crypto investor you
have a thousand Bitcoin you're gonna
live in Dubai you won't pay tax on
anything and those are the countries
that you should look for UAE Singapore
Portugal now it's truly heading in the
wrong direction I mean the EU in general
is heading in the wrong direction you
have other places that are better inside
the EU like Romania you can pay very
little tax also and your Tate talks
about Romania may be one of the reasons
is because the taxes are very low for
people that actually run an operation
there those are the countries you should
look at very low tax potentially zero
like Dubai in the UAE but not
stereotypical tax Havens so can we delve
into why it's so important for wealthy
individuals businesses up and coming
people to leave the US the UK Europe you
mentioned Portugal is no good um well
it's starting to be no good why is it so
important to leave and go somewhere
where they actually pay little taxes you
said that it's your responsibility why
is it your responsibility well you're
basically for example if somebody wants
to break into your house and take all
your stuff and they just have a
toothpick and they want to break through
your door you're basically giving them
an ax so they can go and break your door
even faster so you paying a bunch of tax
is just going to create more
restrictions governments are getting
more controlled for example in the US
now a crypto investor with a U.S
passport has very little access to
crypto products crypto exchanges
compared to somebody with another
passport you can't even access binance
with a US password a lot of exchanges
will make you fill out hundreds of forms
just because you're a U.S citizen banks
will give you trouble and governments
are heading in that direction Canada the
EU as a whole is also heading in that
direction and it's up to you to do
everything within the law absolutely
legal don't hide money anywhere just
protect yourself your freedom your
family as well because as we're going to
talk about later your children will grow
up in a society that was 50 years ago
for example there was none of this
wokeness there was none of this crazy
things that are heading extremely in the
wrong direction there are countries that
still celebrate masculinity femininity
and things that we should see as normal
and I know that you um you work with a
lot of different countries like you
mentioned Romania parts of Europe but
Dubai is where you're based Dubai is
where you recommend so let's get into
this what really is so good about Dubai
why is Dubai better I know uh safety
reasons so let's start there like why is
Dubai so safe and is it really so safe
it really is so safe you can leave your
laptop in a hotel lobby you come back
two hours later security took it and
they put it somewhere safe or it's
literally there and one guy who did it
on Tick Tock he put a laptop on just a
Starbucks left one hour later came back
the laptop was still there wow and there
are very few places that are like this
that nobody breaks into your house you
can leave the door open nothing happens
nobody's gonna steal your car you can
leave your Ferrari with the top open
nothing happens and also very safe for
women because a lot of people they say
that when I tell my mom oh I live in
Dubai is it's safer women there can I go
yes it's extremely safe it's not to the
level of Saudi Arabia where there's this
restriction but it's very few play
places like Dubai I would say Singapore
is also like this and very few other
countries where you can truly live a
safe life not even worry about it I
think that's really attractive because
there's a lot of people who've made a
lot of money and they have these nice
watches nice cars and you know they
can't do anything I mean I wouldn't want
to walk around London with a Rolex on my
wrist you know so so in Dubai people can
really Flex what they've earned is that
right yeah I have Rolexes I didn't bring
them to Miami because I know if I walk
around here with a Rolex I'm gonna have
issues in Dubai you can have a Richard
Mill watch half a million dollars and
nobody cares because there's a lot of
wealth you still need to be careful you
go to the bad areas with a very large
watch or something that's really
eye-catching that's gonna have some
problems but it's not like London at all
I mean everybody that I talked to says
that London is just completely in the
wrong direction and that that's a big
factor for a lot of people so what makes
Dubai so safe
I would say the real reason is because
everybody's a tourist you can get
residency you can get a 10-year Visa you
can get permanent residency to an extent
but if at any point you commit something
that the government seems as okay we can
kick you out they can kick you out there
is no second chances they kick you out
they put you on The Blacklist and you
can't get back in and people don't want
to take that risk like if I if somebody
steals something from you they go on The
Blacklist and they can never come back
is it really worth it and they will
probably catch you there was an example
of a guy on a motorbike he left a
motorbike in front of grocery store went
to the grocery store somebody stole
everything they found them in a couple
hours they deported the guy gave
everything back and that was the end of
it people are not willing to take that
risk that is the real reason and nobody
can become a citizen easily so they can
kick them out at any point that's so
fascinating it's not like in California
well I think in La if there's a crime
under like 700 the police don't do
anything about it
and then that creates more crime and but
one thing which is very different about
Dubai is there's no homeless is that
right explain that to me because even
here in Miami there's homeless there's
homeless everywhere and it's getting
worse
in Dubai there's no homeless the
citizens that are homeless for example
let's say a citizen of the UAE becomes
homeless he gets a free house basically
the government goes here here's an
apartment here's the key go and live
there if there is a foreigner that is a
homeless they ask him go get a job or
leave those are the options and in Dubai
I say that a lot on Instagram and so on
I say either make money or you're a high
status individual or you leave because
there is no other alternative the prices
are very high everything is very
expensive but it's because you get what
you pay for and you cannot just sleep on
the street and they're going to ask you
to do something about them yeah it's so
fascinating to actually hear and see a
country doing something you know that's
active rather than just passive and
letting everything just crumble
um now in terms of families that are
looking to use your services and move to
Dubai let's talk about children we know
that it's safe but what's the schooling
like because obviously I know people are
going to want their kids to be able to
speak English
um you know have maybe an American
diploma or whatever it is so what's the
school like in Dubai schools
specifically those that are registered
as associated with UK schools or U.S
schools you get the diploma from that
country so for example Repton school
which is one that a lot of our clients
like to send their kids because it's a
very high profile school a lot of very
wealthy individuals send their kids
there you get a diploma from the UK If
you graduate but the great thing about
it is you don't have any of the nonsense
of the UK school systems with these drag
queens let's say teaching children or
these people with like transgender flags
all over their classroom and do why you
have none of that so your children are
growing how you want them to grow how
you want them to be thought and you can
also get private tutoring tutors are
everywhere all over Dubai and if you
want them to learn another language or
you want them to have specific education
you can get that it's expensive but you
can get it easily so let's get into that
so you so you can have you can speak
full English you can learn English
beautifully well you could you can
um get a western diploma if that if
that's what you want but without all the
wokeness that's so fascinating because
it just seems like
it's insufferable Now everywhere you go
whether it's even you know just Netflix
TV adverts so there's nobody there's
nobody uh you don't have like men
dressed up in women's clothes and makeup
talking reading books to children in
schools in Dubai you don't have that it
sounds so ridiculous
when I came back to the US for like a
couple days I realized oh this is normal
here but in Dubai you say something like
that and everybody looks at you like no
that's that shouldn't happen and that's
how it is and the government keeps a
tight control there was one transgender
person who tried to enter Dubai they saw
him they saw that it was or her
um they saw that it was a transgender
person they did not allow him to enter
the UAE oh wow so it's at that level
maybe you might say oh they're racist
they don't accept other people but they
want to keep it as it should be and as
you and me believe how the world should
be run so no I I respect that I think I
I can understand you know protectionism
and wanting to keep things that's the
reason why people are spending hundreds
of thousands just remove that because
it's safer that's really just so
interesting and can you tell me a little
bit more um about the schools are they
separate is it is it mixed with genders
or are they are they separated you have
girls schools boys schools how does it
work you have both you have mixed you
also have boys and girls schools usually
it depends on how much you pay the level
of education and also the kind of
diploma that you get so for example
there's a lot of universities that are
associated with for example the
Wollongong University you get an
Australian diploma so for example
Australian family moves to Dubai and
they want their children to get diplomas
from back home because maybe at some
point they'll move back you can do that
and university is more it's more mixed
but you can definitely have boys school
girls school if you want it and there's
a lot of places around Dubai you do need
to pick it carefully because not
everything is designed for families and
kids there's a lot of places that are
just for tourists and for people I just
want to enjoy their time you do need to
pick it carefully but there's a lot of
places for kids to meet other kids and
socialize is it going to get harder to
move to the abide you think
I would say no okay because Dubai isn't
for example like Singapore I often
compare it to Singapore because
Singapore was very easy to move to very
easy to get citizenship to open a bank
account to do anything and now it's
almost impossible you need to have 100
200 million dollars serious money but
Singapore is also very small right so
they cannot expand they cannot go into
other places and just keep building they
just have the small island Dubai is you
can open it up to connecting it to Abu
Dhabi open it up into the desert into
the mountains you basically have an
amazing amount of space that they can
keep building keep expanding I don't
think it's going to get harder maybe
more expensive maybe the government
needs more money for their fees and so
on but definitely not as hard as other
countries have gone in because I know
Panama used to be easy and now it's
really difficult so I'm just wondering
if there's like any urgency to sort of
get the ball rolling you know if
somebody's sitting on the fence about
whether to sort of you know stay in LA
with all the homeless or whether to go
live a nice life with their luxury
watches and everything else I would say
get it set up I always tell people if
you're not ready to move a lot of people
are not just get the residency it takes
three weeks which we're gonna talk about
more it just takes three weeks to get it
set up only one week in Dubai you
explore the city you get your resident
card and then you come back and you
always have it in your back pocket if at
any point you get tired of the homeless
you just move literally the next week
you move because you have the right to
move you open a bank account maybe you
start moving some money you see it
doesn't disappear that it's a safe bank
it's a safe country okay now it's time
to move so it doesn't have to be
tomorrow that you move just set up the
residency there's no time requirement of
actually spending time in Dubai only
land a couple times a year and that's it
okay so let's get into this
um how long does it take so say people
were to go click the link in description
book a consultation with you how long
does it take literally from speaking to
you to then sitting in a really nice
place in Dubai away from all the crazy
wokeness of the world how long is that
how quickly can you move someone in just
two weeks you're going can get fully set
up and then two weeks that's crazy it's
very quick because the Visa processes
most people what they do or what we help
them do is they start a company and they
give themselves a job under that same
company so you could give yourself the
job of the CEO you could give your
girlfriend or parent or whoever the job
of assistant you all get visas you
arrive in Dubai and then you need to do
a quick medical test it's very common
even here in the US if you want to get
residency also need to do a medical test
and then once you pass that that takes
three or four days then you're
officially a resident so it's one week
in Dubai two weeks out and everything is
done oh wow so at any time so quick so
how much does this cost and what exactly
are you doing for these people I know
there must be lawyers forms documents
visas medical tests like what are you
doing and do you do everything we do
everything we start from the company
incorporation then doing the whole job
process that they need to apply for the
job inside their own company then the
Visa medical tests residency bank
accounts as well and also because a lot
of people are living High tax countries
and also restrictive countries you can't
just leave America tomorrow and then
pretend okay IRS I'm out no they want
some sort of money from you if you've
spent enough time this year they want
money for this year maybe they want an
exit tax if you actually want to escape
the tax system most countries want that
you need to talk to tax lawyers in your
country and we have those as well we
prepare the whole thing from leaving a
high tax country to arriving in a low
tax zero tax country like Dubai
everything needs to be connected to be
fully legal this this is the place where
you can't make mistakes some places you
can make some mistakes here and there
this is all very punishable so this all
has to be done properly and sometimes it
takes longer just the three weeks for
Dubai maybe longer to get out of your
country but we take care of everything a
lot of my audience and a lot of the New
Wealth that we see in today's world is
very much very much comes from crypto
um so I have a couple of questions
um for the crypto people the first
question is
I know a lot of people have crypto in
non-kyc non-custody wallets that nobody
knows about right that they can't spend
and so if they leave the US they leave
the UK or whatever and they go to
um Dubai and this crypto which they
haven't declared because I don't know
they just didn't declare it what does
that mean for that crypto can they just
legitimize it and bring it onshore I
don't know if I'm saying that right in
Dubai obviously unfortunately no okay
that all is taxable back home okay
before you leave so if you have 100
Bitcoin at the time that you left your
country that's all taxable on all the
gains until you leave
so that's why I tell people the bear
market for example is the best time to
leave because you're at a loss or you
just bought a bunch of crypto right now
when it goes up you want to be somewhere
else yes you can have it all in a vault
in a Tresor Ledger and then only kyc it
but you would be committing tax evasion
that's illegal at that point and I'm not
gonna advise yeah yeah so you really
need to be careful when you escape and
when you actually transfer those funds
that's yeah that's important that's
really interesting I actually noted so
that would that would be tax evasion
basically okay interesting so a bear
Market is the best time to move yes so
once somebody's moved and you know that
they have
um all this new capital because we're in
a bull market what what are the capital
gains taxes
in Dubai or yeah how does that work in
Dubai do they pay any capital gains tax
do they have to pay anything back home
like how does it work for American
versus British no in Dubai would be zero
so basically if you make a million
dollars in capital gains that's all
taxable at zero percent tax
the only country that taxes based on
your passport is the US so if you have a
U.S passport a US green card you pay tax
no matter what you pay at the regular
rate and you're screwed if you're from
anywhere else in the world if you did it
properly and you escaped your country
properly then you're not taxable back
home unless this all all depends how
much time you spent in your country and
the law in that country so if you spent
six months in the UK let's say this year
and next week you move to Dubai you cash
it all out in Dubai the whole year is
taxable because you spent more than six
months most countries have that law so
it all depends how much time you spend
in the year what kind of passport you
have the US password being the exception
but in Dubai you don't even need to
report it you just literally cash it out
and do nothing that's amazing I feel
like I need to move to Dubai now
um so once they do cash out how crypto
friendly is Dubai like can you buy
properties with crypto can you buy cars
with crypto like what can you do with
crypto and Dubai definitely cars
property anything you're liking cash it
out very easily so a lot of my clients
are example they have three million five
million dollars they cash it out you pay
a small percentage and then it's in your
bank account it's in cash and you can
use it to buy things so crypto overall
very easy to use you can't use it at the
coffee shop or at the grocery store we
still don't have that but very easy to
use the only thing I will say is that
banks are not that crypto friendly in
Dubai that's the only thing so for
example a U.S Bank even though they're
they're very restrictive as well but if
you cash out money from an exchange like
coinbase they typically don't give you
problems in Dubai you do have to be
careful because the Central Bank of
Dubai doesn't like crypto too much it's
their competition essentially so you
can't just send a bunch of crypto to the
bank account cash it out easily you need
to be very careful depending on the
amount and we also help people okay so
you you help with all these different
okay that's amazing um and what
companies
um end up establishing businesses in
Dubai and to what extent is it a
headache or do you guys just make it
really simple and smooth and take care
of everything we usually make it very
simple the only only thing is people
that have a lot of employees back home
so let's say you run a crypto exchange
as an example for crypto you have 100
people back in the UK that are living
there and you want to move them over to
Dubai or you want to pay less tax in the
UK that becomes very complex because the
UK will see that you have 100 people
there the money's coming from the UK all
these people are making your money
therefore it needs to pay tax in the UK
those are the most complex we need to
work with multiple lawyers we need to
move a lot of those people we need to
create more people in Dubai than in the
UK those are the most complex those take
months even years to do but the ones
where you just run your own company your
own Investments that's a two-week
process
so everyone right now is talking about
leaving the Matrix um Andrew Tate
popularized that um Dubai is obviously
um the place where everyone wants to go
so who would you say the perfect
individual is to move is it somebody
who's already made their money is it
somebody who's you know an entrepreneur
that's on their way up women on their
own men on their own families like who
is the perfect person to move to Dubai I
would say many people can move for
example like Andrew Tate he already made
a lot of his wealth and where is he now
Dubai he's set up in Dubai and he's
afraid of many other countries he says
he won't come back to America because he
has problems here or maybe they they
really don't like him here he'll just
stay in Dubai happy safe nobody will
steal anything from him and that's the
example the perfect example the person
that is in the in the Muse every day and
it doesn't have to be at that level you
don't need to be a hundred millionaire
to move to Dubai directly you can be on
the come up so you know that next year
you're going to make a couple million
dollars or you're just growing fast move
now so you don't need to move and then
worry about a bunch of taxes or exit
taxes or pay tax now and then later on
move I would say at any point it's fine
to move I've even helped some clients
that are lone women like just a woman
that runs her own business she doesn't
have a boyfriend or husband she just
moves to Dubai directly and that's also
fine there's no restrictions on that
anything like that so at any level as
long as you have like we were talking
about before let's say at least fifteen
twenty thousand dollars minimum to move
to Dubai and also Dubai is probably more
expensive than where you're coming from
so the rent is going to be more
expensive just be aware that you will
spend more money on day-to-day life out
of Interest how much is like a one bed
two-bed apartment just off the top of
your head you know in Dubai in a very
good area a two-bedroom quite luxurious
I would say 600 000 650 000 but you're
talking with a nice view in the marina
and if you're renting
renting the rentals are actually quite
High compared to other places like Miami
so my apartment right now I'm not going
to say where it is or anything but it's
around 7 500 a month okay and it's a two
bedroom and it looks really nice with a
good view and everything and that's
typically what you'll pay 7 500 10 000
for a really nice two bedroom I think
that's the same as Miami yeah yeah I
mean the prices have like gone up pay I
think Miami's the place where it's like
doubled the most in the last year
actually so so yeah that that sounds
great because at least you know at least
in Dubai or paying so much money but
like they don't tax you so it's sort of
like it balances out in some ways so how
does somebody get in touch with you if
they want to start an application and
actually move abroad and legally pay
zero taxes just go to the website in the
description here and book a call with us
we have a big team that we actually
advise you on many things not just the
tax but also if Dubai fits you properly
because if you're looking for a place
that has a lot of mountains a lot of
greenery forests Dubai is probably
enough for you because it's middle of
the desert sort of so we also help you
with what kind of choices depend on you
and what country you're coming from
what's the strategy so just book a call
with us what advice you're on that call
and then we'll go from there is there
anything else that we've missed or
anything else you feel like you you want
to explain about the services that you
offer I would say I do want to touch on
the downsides of Dubai because people
will probably say that oh Dubai is not
this magical place they have this and
this and this and this yeah let's do
that so I would probably say there's a
lot of people that say that oh there's
like slavery or there's mother modern
slavery in Dubai and that's a
misconception a lot of people have that
they think they don't want to move they
don't want to support that but most of
these people coming from third world
countries let's call them for example
India they move to Dubai and they're
sending a lot of money back home okay so
yes they might not be living a luxury
life a really nice life but they're
making a lot of money that back home
their parents are buying homes they're
buying cars with so Dubai yes it's built
with a lot of third world labor but
these people are making their families
rich and they're going to come back and
they're going to be rich back home so
that's one thing and the second thing I
would say that is kind of true is the
nature there's not that much nature
unfortunately yeah so that's why I
recommend people you be in Dubai in the
summer when it gets quite hot you fly to
Europe you fly to other places I was in
Australia in summer exploring it a bit
so there are options and Emirates
airline flies literally every everywhere
that yeah that's so fascinating
um I was there actually in the summer
for a little bit and it was crazy crazy
hot so no I I get that Raphael thank you
so much for coming on the show it's been
such a pleasure speaking with you and I
think when I'm ready I will definitely
have to check out moving to Dubai
somehow definitely
all right guys I hope you found this
segment useful
um I have left a link in the description
for you so if you are ready to level up
your life and legally pay zero taxes
then definitely check out wealthy expat
I think they're the number one people to
go to when it comes to leaving The
Matrix